earlier this week you discussed
announced their new video game
Assassin's Creed origins a prequel to
their popular game series about an
ancient Egyptian warrior who forms a
brotherhood of assassins dedicated to
one day getting 18 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes but what if you're going to you
should have voted for it but
what really blew the collective minds of
the internet was that Ubisoft will offer
a collector's edition of the game that
costs $800 yes for the price of a minor
surgery you can now get of a map of a
place you can't visit a statue of a
game's main character who kind of looks
like they put a hood on the guy from
jersey shore and the coup de Gras what
every kid wants a premium Eagle skull
amulet not one of those
discount knockoff Costco generic Eagle
skull amulets a premium one of those
because you can never have enough
ambulance more ambulance I say ambulance
all day for me Chris Hardwick is the
perfect accessory to wear while buying
an energy drink in your sweatpants so
comedians Ubisoft is really starting a
trend here what items will be in other
video games insanely expensive
collector's edition Ryan stout Madden
NFL gives you an unregistered handgun a
DUI and a concussion yeah oh okay and
I'm not sure I should say this but it's
true they also give you brass knuckles
that say white oh well okay hello oh
what up Ryan you had him yeah Adam
Poinciana minecraft comes with a lonely
mom trying desperately to connect to her
kids
not gonna happen these kids today to
understand eye contact
all right Jerry the guitar hero actually
comes with the band Poison all right boy